so with a lot of the stories that we've
been doing recently being pretty serious
I thought it'd be fun to take a break
away from the serious tone of a lot of
these stories and just focus on
something fun focus on something
different and so what we'll be doing is
we'll be talking about for who in the
what-if universe became a Herald of
Galactus
so the what if universe are there
basically an alternate universe is there
stories where by events would have
transpired in a different way where
sometimes events that have never
happened would actually end up happening
and so with this story what we do is we
pick up with Galactus as he's arrived at
Asgard and Galactus of course is doing
what he does and stating that he intends
to consume Asgard and so his Herald
which isn't actually given to us we
don't really know what her name is
begins I guess attacking asgaard along
with the Warriors three and a way to
basically eliminate any kind of
resistance that exists here and so what
happens is that loki initially tells
Thor he has to stay behind that he has
to help Loki figure out a way to destroy
the Machine of Galactus so that Galactus
cannot consume Asgard but Thor says no
Thor begins attacking a Galactus
alongside the Warriors three and so as a
result Thor successful in killing The
Herald of Galactus and he basically
challenges I guess issues this kind of
statement saying that there really
aren't any battles that he's faced that
can't be won and so what happens is
Galactus offers Thor the opportunity to
become as Herald and Thor initially says
no he says that that it would basically
defy everything that he stands for
regarding Asgard but Galactus points out
the fact that that really isn't anything
left to stay in for with Asgard because
Asghar it's been almost entirely
destroyed and so what Galactus says is
that if Thor chooses to become his
Herald that Galactus will leave Asgard
and that he will never return pretty
much the same kind of sort of stance we
saw with Norrin Radd and Galactus in
terms of Norrin Radd becoming the Silver
Surfer and so what happens here is Thor
undertakes the role of becoming The
Herald of Galactus but as he's
travelling throughout the cosmos what we
find is that he's basically picking
planets that have very harsh forms of
life that he's not picking planets
indiscriminately and what Galactus says
is he knows the Thor has been doing this
but the problem here is that Thor
picking or I guess going through and
weeding out only specific kinds of
planets pretty much prolong the hunger
that Galactus has in the sense that
Galactus will eventually just start
grabbing planets at random as opposed to
picking the planets Authority uses
because Thor is making Galactus wait in
order to feed and so what happens is
that while Thor is I guess effectively
serving as the The Herald for Galactus
that it receives some info
Meishan from one of the crows of odin
and what the crow tells him is that loki
and during the absence of thor has
basically seized Asgard and that he's
killed Odin and so Thor initially tries
to leave he tries to tell over I'm sorry
trying to talk about like I said he's
going to travel back to Asgard but
collector says no the Galactus says that
Thor's agreement was for the protection
of Asgard but not protection of Asgard
from anybody other than Galactus and so
what Thor says is he basically
challenges Galactus here and saying that
either Galactus can let him leave or
Galactus can kill him as he tries to
leave and so goal I just not wanting to
kill Thor simply lets him go and so once
Thor arrives back at Asgard he confronts
Loki and Loki of course again is working
along the frost rise here which is
pretty standard for the actions of Loki
whenever he's working with anybody in
particular and so what for says is that
Loki's destroyed everything that that
Asgard stands for but what Thor also
realizes is that once he enters the I
guess the funeral room of Odin that he
finds his hammer still there and he
picks the hammer up realizing that not
only is he able to wield a hammer of
Thor but that he's also able to as a I
guess he's still in possession of the
power cosmic and so as a result he has
hitherto unknown challenged abilities in
relation to Loki and so what happens is
he begins to come battle oogie but he
also says that he'll have help and so
once the members of the Warriors three
are freed along with various other as
Guardians we also see the Galactus
arrives now this is where things get
really interesting what Thor says is
that because a scart has basically been
destroyed by Loki because there's really
nothing left of the honour of Asgard
he basically abandons it and so what he
does is he leaves look you to his fate
and he tells Galactus that he can
consume Asgard he also has the warriors
three take all the other ask Guardians
and send them to the planet Earth and so
what happens when when he's asked
whether or not he's going to be
travelling with anybody simply says no
he says his side is I guess is our role
is now at the side of Galactus and he
continues about being Galactus Herald
presumably leading Galactus to other
planets throughout the cosmic
with that being said we're going to
ahead and bring this video to an end I
hope you guys enjoyed it if you did let
me know and I will catch you guys later
peace be sure to follow me on Twitter
there you can keep up with all the
updates from comments explained and talk
to me directly